we have to talk about the Corona virus outbreak
that is taking place worldwide.
And I know that all week I've been getting
emails from people saying, David, when are
you going to talk about this? And honestly,
what's had me not talk about it so far is
that I don't want to be spreading fear and
panic about disease outbreaks. Um, and we
were really careful back during the highly
politicized, the Bola situation during the
2014 midterms. I lived in New York city at
the time and there was famously a, uh, a person
who came back from, I don't remember where
in West Africa, went to Brooklyn bowl, uh,
Brooklyn, the Brooklyn bowl near where I lived
in Brooklyn. And uh, turned out that, uh,
he had symptoms, had Ebola and uh, the, the
term he bowling started showing up on Twitter
and a lot of panic started to spread. And
as it turned out, a lot of that Ebola situation
was very political.
The day after the 2014 midterms, you didn't
hear a, almost a word about the Ebola so-called
outbreak. So I want to be careful about not
spreading irrational fear and panic. So to
begin with, the Corona virus outbreak is an
outbreak. It is not a pandemic that is not
the right word to assign to it right now.
Corona virus. This particular Corona virus
is known as 2019 end cov. It is considered
a respiratory illness. Initially it seems
as though the source is a Wu Han China and
specifically it seemed like it was a seafood
and meat market in Wu Han, which suggested
animal to person spread. That has started
to change because there are more and more
patients that have had no exposure to animal
markets suggesting person to person transmission
could be both. Right now it's just not completely
clear based on what the CDC has put out in
general.
Corona viruses are um, uh, uh, coming from
animals. Uh, they can come from camels, cattle,
cats, bats and some other animals. When it
spreads between people, it is often via respiratory
droplets, meaning you cough or you sneeze
and there are microdroplets someone else breeze
them in or it gets into their, um, uh, uh,
membranes. Uh, in other ways it's still unclear.
Again, a lot of this is still under development.
Under investigation symptoms are typically
fever, cough and shortness of breath. The
symptoms sometimes don't appear for 14 days
after exposure, which makes this very tricky,
but it does mean if you've been in China within
the last two weeks or around people who came
back from China during that time and you have
symptoms, you should immediately call your
doctor. There have been deaths from this,
there have been deaths from this and we'll
get to those numbers in a, again, the outbreaks
centered around Wu Han, China.
We actually have a few viewers in that region.
Cases have been spreading in terms of countries.
Uh, you have China of course affected as well
as Hong Kong, Macau, Taiwan, Australia, Cambodia,
Canada, France, Germany, Japan, Malaysia,
Nepal, Sri Lanka, Singapore, Thailand, South
Korea, the UAE, the U S and Vietnam. I read
this morning in an Argentinian newspaper that
there were a couple of cases under observation
in Peru. As of right now, it's unclear whether
that is or is not. This strain of Corona virus.
It has reached the United States as of this
morning. There are cases confirmed in Washington
state, California, Arizona and Illinois. Five
patients testing positive in total by the
time you listen to or watch this segment,
that number may have increased no vaccine
right now there are basic prevention measures.
Hand-washing for at least 20 seconds, coughing
and sneezing as I call it. With respect, I
am shocked almost daily about the number of
adults who seem to either not understand this
or not care walking around people just coughing
into the open air right on top of me on public
transit at the grocery store.
How do we not know this at this point? Okay.
If you were sick, stay home difficult when
a lot of people can't afford to miss work,
I get it, but if you're sick, stay home is
the directive. If you're traveling by airplane,
you've got to be an adult in terms of the
symptoms. Now the directive is if you feel
feverish or have a fever, you've got to tell
the airline you've got to be taken off the
flight. Now. I know if you're at the end of
a long trip and it's time to get on the plane
and you're not feeling well, most people want
to get home unless it is so acute that you
need to go to a hospital right away. Most
people rationalize, I'll be better off at
home than abroad if I'm sick. I don't want
to be stuck here. I want to see my doctor.
I'll pretend I'm fine. I'm not going to mention
my fever. I'm going to get on the plane. I
get it, okay, but we've got to do the right
thing because this is going to continue to
spread. If you're having symptoms and you
are going to your doctor, call ahead, tell
them it's conceivable that you have this so
that they can take the right steps to make
sure you don't show up and get other people
sick. Where one of those face masks when you're
with other people and that you're at your
doctor's office, you may be asked to wear
one. Just do it if you have pets, and this
is important because there does appear to
be animal human contagion here. You've got
to try to avoid touching your pets because
this can spread from humans to animals. We
just don't know everything about it yet and
if you have to have contact with your pets,
as most of you do, if you understand the psychology
of dogs, it's hard not to be near your dog.
You may want to consider wearing one of the
masks around your pets as well. So let's work
together to stop the spread right now about
7,700 cases worldwide. All but 68 of those
are in mainland China. The death toll currently
one 30 mostly older folks as of now, so we're
going to be following it. This is not about
panicking people, but this is about understanding
the risks
and
the spread
and what's going on.